[Music]
three years ago
everyone at the touch woke up
with a power touched
rewriting the rules of reality i want
them under control
[Applause]
even if it requires a bloodletting
i will cut your face to a mess
you know the touch yes they have weird
deformities and afflictions
they're unhappy well whatever they are
i think they're a gold mine
you know what a better world could be
like is that the mission you were going
on about
yes i do have a mission and i'm not cut
out for it
but it matters
there's a harmony to our world that's
worth preserving
the touched are not a threat yet you
seem determined to prove that they are
the church the purists they're a danger
to us
we have enemies we don't know about yet
oops
i am here for a reason our first
response cannot be hate we'll be lined
up in the streets
i want the wicked punished and the good
protected
you often engage in public violence i
know where i am in a fight because i see
glimpses of the future
something happened
it's not fun watching you throw yourself
a dng like you think it's gonna propose
could be fun
there's savagery chaos
attached need protection and i need
information
about why we're here and what we're
meant to do next
we're taking a terrible risk the future
of the world depends on what i'm doing
the future of the world depends on the
present
attached a part of something much bigger
[Music]
you